so I have a very simple equation written
here a plus B is equal to C and what I
want to think about if we know that a is
an integer so let's say that this is the
set of all integers right over here
integers we know that a is an integer so
let's say that's a there we also know
that B is an integer it could be the
same integer but I'll draw it so it
looks like it's another one but doesn't
have to be they could be the same
integer B is an integer if we're adding
these two integers are we definitely
going to get another integer do we know
that C is going to be an integer and I
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it well when you thought
about you might have come up with some
cases well what if a and B are both 1
then for sure C is going to be 2 and C
is going to be an integer well is that
always going to be the case well it is
there are ways to prove it I'm not going
to go into it now but when you have a
situation like this when you're able to
take two members of a set in this case
two members of a set and perform an
operation on it and always get another
member of the set and it could be a or B
again or it could be another distinct
member of the set I'll draw it as
another distinct member of the set
whenever you have this so you have some
operation in this case it is addition so
when you're performing the addition
operation on two members of the set you
get you stay in the set C is also going
to be a member of that set so one way to
think about it we're going we're going
like this and we are performing this
addition operation whenever you see a
circumstance like this we call we say
that this set the set of integers is
closed under addition let me write that
down so this means that the set of
integers integers is closed under under
addition so once again you're going to
hear this idea of closure as the general
term that we're talking about is closure
when you take some especially higher
mathematics course but you might even
hear it in some of your high school
courses and it might seem like this
really advanced thing but all it's
saying is you have a set you have some
operation that you can perform on
members of
set and if every time you perform that
operation on members of the set you get
you stay in the set the result is a
member of the set then you say that the
set is closed under that operation the
set is closed in this case the operation
is addition you say the set is closed
under addition and we can ask ourselves
that same question about other things is
the set of is the set of integers closed
under closed under actually let's take
some examples is it closed under
multiplication multi-application and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it and then think about is
it closed under division is it closed
under division is it closed under
subtraction is it closed under
subtraction I encourage you to think
about all these different operations
let's take them one by one
multiplication if you take two integers
and you were to multiply it you actually
will always get another integer so the
set of integers is closed under
multiplication
now what about division well it's very
easy to prove a case in which I'm up I'm
dividing two integers and not getting
another integer for example I could say
let me just do a very simple 1 1 divided
by 2 1 & 2 are both integers but what's
that going to give me that's going to
give me 1/2 which is not another integer
this is a rational number but not an
integer so if we were to extend our sets
right over here all integers are also
rational but all rationals are not
integers necessarily so this is
irrational rational numbers here this
case of 1/2 so that's 1 and this is 2
when we performed division we went out
of the set so when we performed division
we went out of that set to something
that's not an integer but it is a
rational number so the set of integers
is not closed under division subtraction
sure and once again I'm not going to
rigorously prove it here but take any
two integers you indeed are going to get
another you are going to get a another
integer so the whole idea here is to
just give you a brief introduction to
the notion
of closure the idea that if you have a
set and if you perform an operation on
members of that set and you always get a
member of your original set then that
then that set is closed under that
operation now what did Matt what matters
is is the set that you're talking about
in this case we talked a lot about
integers and we talked about addition
multiplication division subtraction but
you could think about the set of
polynomials and whether they are closed
under addition which they actually are
or the set of rational numbers are they
closed under exponentiation there's all
sorts of things we could think about but
hopefully this gives you a good sense of
what we mean when we say closure or for
a set being closed under some operation